oh okay we'll begin and open this
session of division 3 on October 3
2023 so good morning to everybody uh for
the record I am representative Moren
money the vice chair of division 3 here
in house finance our chairman
representative Jess Edwards had a
planned absence today but we'll be back
with us either later this month or early
next month and we look forward uh to
that so we have a couple of replacements
today on the committee to announce uh
first of all as I mentioned
representative Edwards is absent today
and so representative Jim kofalt is
taking the place of Representative
Edwards and then our clerk
representative Jerry Stringham is out
today and so representative Chuck grassy
will take his place today the clerk for
today will be representative Wier so
thank you very much for uh taking that
role today's meeting the work session
has been properly noticed and uh here we
are Live on YouTube and certainly open
to the public we have seven bills to
take up today and our purpose is to
discuss them and then vote on a
recommendation for the Full House of
finance committee to take up and then
the full Finance committee's
recommendation will go to the Full House
in accordance with uh house rule
45 we're entering now the second year of
this session therefore our
recommendations on the bills can be one
of the following ought to pass ought to
pass with Amendment itl or inum
study all of those
recommendations uh having gone through
house finance go to the Full
House all retained bills have to be out
of their committees by November 17th so
we are perfectly in ahead of schedule
within the time frame there and I
imagine notice soon will come about as
to when the full finance committee will
meet to take up our recommendations as
well as those of Divisions one and
two we don't have to worry about blurbs
today uh we'll worry about that when uh
we meet as a full finance committee but
certainly keep in mind that those will
be needed so if any suit your fancy to
write I'm sure uh we'd be open to that
okay those are my introductory remarks
anything from the membership before we
dive
in all right we're going to start with
the house bill
91 and that is an act relative to
privacy obligations of the Department of
Health and Human
Services uh many of these several of
these Bill stand we will'll go through
them but one of which this is one is in
House Bill 2 and that appears in
sections 79 colon
425 through 79 colon
427 in the final version of House Bill
two so House Bill 91 do we have a motion
to discuss on House Bill
91 representative hle for a
motion I would move itl in that this is
already
done okay the motion is itl is there a
second second of Representative
walner on House Bill 91 itl again it
does appear in House Bill two in the
sections I referenced any discussion on
House Bill 91 motion to
itl okay at that point we will take the
role whenever the clerk is
ready all right representative
Kofa
yes representative
Earth yes
yes I'll do that representative hle yes
representative walner yes representative
nordgren yes representative tersi yes
representative grassy
yes representative Mooney yes wer votes
yes
all right one two
three nine
yes zero no okay nine to zero the motion
is itl House Bill
91 next we're going to move to House
Bill
282 this is an act relative to including
certain children and pregnant women in
Medicaid in the children's health
insurance
program uh just as a reference the bill
has been Incorporated in House Bill 2
which was adopted earlier this year
specifically section 79 colon
412 the sponsor of the bill is here in
the room that's representative Shapiro
representative Shapiro would you like to
make any remarks with regards to your
bill at this
point
thank you madam chair um I was honored
to bring this bill um and very pleased
to see that it was um entered into House
Bill 2 this is a bill that will um ease
eligibility criteria for Medicade for
lawfully residing immigrants who are
children or pregnant women um with this
being signed into law we will be joining
all the other states in the Northeast
and also
about 35 out of the 50 states in the
country so um I'm very pleased that this
was put in the budget and I don't see
any reason why it shouldn't be ited at
this
point thank you for those remarks any
comments or questions there thank you
very much representative at this point
I'll take a motion on House Bill 282
representative hle sure I mve to itl
House Bill 282 okay itl on 282 is there
a second representative tarki for a
second any discussion on an itl
motion okay Mr clerk when you're
ready oall
yes F
yes pole
yes walner yes nren yes lurki yes grassy
yes chairman
Mooney yes wer votes yes nine to
zero okay nine to zero the motion
carries on House Bill 282
itl next we'll move to House Bill
527 that is an act relative to Medicaid
reimbursement rates for certain assisted
living
facilities one of the sponsors of the
bill is in the room representative Horan
so I'd like to give you the courtesy
your choice if you'd like to address the
division 3 work session at this
point Thank you madam chair good
morning I just wanted to remind
everybody that uh this is for small size
facility 16 beds or less uh requires uh
a makeup of 50% or more of lowincome
residents and that uh the current rate
is I think
5688 we're asking for 115 in this and
that
uh the average monthly cost for a
resident is roughly
$4,500 the current amount doesn't quite
get us there and 115 doesn't pay all the
bills but it definitely uh eases some of
the burden because from the low income
we relying on social security and
whatever income may exist uh
so it helps considerably and a raise
would be most
appreciated and that's all I
have thank you representative for taking
the time on your bill we appreciate that
representative
tersi thank you I don't know if this is
a question for the chair or the sponsor
but I'm curious if we have any analysis
of what this type of home is now going
to be receiving under our the new budget
that was passed and signed into law that
raise
rates thank you for that and I'm glad
you brought that out in the House Bill 2
version that we passed section 79 colon
239 we set various rates increasing them
and it's my understanding that a
breakdown analysis hasn't been fully
done
however a home such as representative
Horgan is talking about would receive
approximately
$80 as opposed to the 115 he's asking
for but certainly different from the 56
he's
getting uh at this point I'm going to
ask Mr Ripple for the technicalities on
what I've said and to fill in any
loopholes there that I may have missed
sure yes so the Section House Bill 2
that you referenced didn't specify a
rate but it did provide a little over
$700,000 in fiscal 24 and a little over
1.4 million in fiscal 25 uh for the
purpose of increasing rates to assisted
living facilities I think in the trailer
bill that would apply to all assisted
living facilities rather than only the
ones specified by this bill and I don't
know what daily rate it would bring them
to I think it would be somewhat less
than $80 because um when I look at the
spreadsheet provided by Jim Monahan
during the budget session he was asking
for 2.5 million per year to bring rates
to $80 and this provides 1.5 4 million
per year when fully implemented so I
would need to look to the department to
get the daily rate that this would
provide okay anything further then at
this point I would look for a motion on
House Bill
527 when the members are
ready representative f um I make a
motion to it tell this and I could speak
to my motion okay a motion's been made
to itl is there a second representative
hle for a second representative
Earth so as I understand the process
that's ongoing and I think we're going
to hear more about
this um later this month in the fiscal
committee the uh rate structure that has
has been developed by HHS and I don't
he's not here is
he um is intended to balance the rates
across not just across all these
assisted facilities but across all the
Medicaid rates um in general and just
bumping up one particular the rate for
one
particular class of workers who same
class Works in other environments but
not adjusting them in those other
environments um wouldn't be appropriate
so I think you'll find that the rates
are as being said here would be would
increase the rates as described and
furthermore maintain the consistency
across all the different rate structures
of the Medicaid uh program that we um I
think we allocated $134 million if I'm
not mistaken to um adjust the med
medicate adjust Medicaid rates pretty
much across the board thank
you further discussion on an itl motion
House Bill
okay when the clerk is ready uh to call
the role
representative Kofa
yes
representative yes representative Hull
yes representative walner yes
representative nordgren yes
representative tersi yes representative
grassy
yes chairman Mooney yes wer votes yes 9
to
Zer okay 9 to zero a motion of uh itl
passes is on House Bill
527 and uh thank you again
representative thank you thank you
all okay next House Bill
565 that's an act relative to expanding
Medicaid to include certain postpartum
health care
services that bill has been absorbed in
House Bill two that we passed earlier
this year specif specifically section 79
colon
421 at this point I would entertain a
motion on House Bill 565 representative
H sure I move itl itl on 565 house bill
is there a second second representative
walner any
discussion okay when the clerk is ready
please call the
role
representative kofalt
yes representative F yes representative
Hull
yes representative walner yes
representative nordgren yes
representative tki yes representative
Stringham grassy yes grassy hadn't
written that in yet sorry
representative grassy yes wer votes yes
chairman money yes 9 to
zero okay nine to zero motion carries of
itl on House Bill
565 next we move to House Bill
614 this is an act making an
appropriation to the Department of
Health and Human Services to fund the
meramac new hampsh sure kidney cancer
incidence phase 3 feasibility
study uh this bill also has been
included in House Bill 2 that we passed
earlier this year specifically in
section 79 colon
429 and being from miramac and that's
the town I represent we are extremely
grateful not only to house finance but
the Full House for incorporating this
very important phase three study uh into
the budget and we're looking forward to
uh having that take place over time with
that would anyone like to make a motion
on House Bill five uh
614 representative H for a motion sure I
move itl itl on House Bill 614 is there
a
second second by representative F any
discussion all
right
when the clerk is ready uh call the
role itl on House Bill
614 representative Kofa yes
representative F yes representative hle
yes representa walner yes represent
nren she St there she's gone represent
tersi yes represent grassy yes wer votes
yes chairman Mooney yes 8 to
Z okay 8 to Zer the itl motion passes on
House Bill
614 moving on
now to Senate Bill
263 representative
walner I'll move o to
pass okay and ought to pass pass motion
on Senate Bill 263
uh is there a second representative
tarki for a second uh this is an act
extending the New Hampshire Granite
Advantage healthc Care Program and
reestablishing the commission to
evaluate the effectiveness and future of
the New Hampshire granted Advantage
Healthcare program uh representative
walner would you like to speak to your
motion yes by um making an a toass
motion and uh putting this bill as
autopass it would
um make Medicaid expansion a permanent
permanent as opposed to what's in the um
budget at this point who who made the
second thank
you okay thank you for that
representative
Hull thank you representative walner I I
hear the comment but for a program of
this size um a re-evaluation at the
seven-year Mark I think is where we
settled in the budget is is a reasonable
um is a reasonable decision and I can't
support the autopass because of
that thank you uh just to add that this
uh bill is not fully incorporated into
the budget but it is as you say
partially with a seven-year extension
and that appears in section of House
Bill 279 colon
405 okay the motion is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 263 any further
discussion okay when the clerk is
ready Representative kofalt
no representative F
no representative Hull
no representative
walner represent nordgren
yes represent tki yes
representative grassy
yes wer votes
no chairman Mooney
No 5 to
four five to four the ought to pass
motion fails as a recommendation of the
full finance committee on Senate Bill
263 is there an alternative motion at
this
point representative f um I'd move itl
okay itl with a second of Representative
hle any discussion on an itl motion
Senate Bill
263 all right I would imagine the
discussion would be very similar to the
previous motion is my guess so when the
clerk is ready to call the
[Music]
role I believe it was whole and Earth on
the
motion it was actually
Earth that made the motion and hole that
seconded all right thank you trying to
catch up
here Madam
chair yes representative pole if I may
before we call the role um just
something to note our federal government
is now
$100,000 in debt per person and we're
counting on them to fund a portion of
this program and the current debt is not
sustainable so when we start making
promises to our citizens based on
commitments from the federal government
and it doesn't look like they're going
to sustain it we've got to be
careful okay thank you on the motion of
itl Representative kofalt
yes representative F yes representative
Hull
yes representative
walner Representative nordgren no
Representative tersi
no Representative grassie
no wer votes
yes chairman Mooney
yes 5 to four on
itl okay vote being 5 to four in itl
that motion carries on Senate Bill
263 and again all of these
recommendations go to the full finance
committee uh for further discussion and
recommendation lastly and we're breezing
right through so this has been great
this is very good uh lastly Senate Bill
239 and that is an act relative to the
use of harm reduction services to treat
alcohol and other substance
misuse uh we recently had a work session
on that earlier um in the year and also
uh just recently well actually it was in
June so mid year I know we have
representative Shapiro were you
interested in
speaking at this point on the
bill okay at this point I'll represent
I'll recognize representative
Shapiro thank you madam chair um this is
a bill um that came through Health and
Human Services committee um that
incorporates um harm reduction into the
current statutes um there was a great
deal of support for it um in our
committee and I think in general but
there have been contentious questions
about how to define harm reduction
because um some people have been
concerned
about
other things being added in the future
that we don't even know about or I think
specifically about safe injection sites
which there is not a consensus um in New
Hampshire about including so I think
that is where the sticking point in this
bill
comes um I assumed that we were going to
have a continued session today which is
why I came um but other people who were
involved in that are not here um I'm
probably not the best person to talk
about this because
um I'm not that picky about the
definition that we use I would have
supported this bill with the original
definition or any of the other
definitions that have been mentioned um
so I would support an or to pass on this
Bill thank you for that any further
followup representative
walner thank you so the Health and Human
Services committee passed this bill and
it came came to
finance presumably to look at the
financial ramifications of it but the
Health and Human Services committee
actually felt the bill was in good shape
and ready to come to the
floor and ready to be
passed I really should have looked to
see what the vote was in our committee
um so if somebody could do that that
would be helpful um but I it wouldn't be
here if we didn't pass it and I I think
there was fairly broad consensus not
complete consensus but fairly broad
consensus that the bill was in good
shape um maybe representative kofalt
could speak further I have
it thank you for that and also uh
looking at the May 12th 2023 House
calendar uh that it looks like the bill
came out of committee without
recommendation representative Co
fault thank you so I sit on Health and
Human Services as well and I think think
the I'll say I believe that there was um
consensus as to the need for um some
kind of harm reduction
um harm reduction legislation and it's
something that we need to look at the
concern that some of us on the committee
had had to do with the definition of
harm reduction um I was concerned about
that another Committee Member and I drew
up a flooor Amendment which passed which
further clarified the definition of harm
reduction um and that's we passed the
floor Amendment as a house and then we
passed the the bill with the floor
Amendment um having said that I have
spoken to several members of the
committee who have subsequently Express
concern who who like myself voted for
the bill at that time have have have
subsequently um raised concerns relative
to the definition of harm reduction and
what it might incompass and how that is
being used in other states in particular
and around the world um
so you know our I I I guess I'll speak
for myself in saying that I think that
this bill addresses some very important
concerns having said that um I think
that considerable further discussion is
required to narrow and clarify that
definition of harm reduction because
right now um despite our efforts to to
Define it more clearly it seems like it
is um still not clearly defined um as as
it needs to
be representative Hull thank you madam
chair having in my past worked at a drug
and alcohol rehab for two years this is
a real issue and I fully understand it
but I'm not sure the legisl that we're
looking at right now actually will
address some of the core issues um that
need to be addressed and terms like harm
reduction that representative Cal just
mentioned are vague um there are some
other things that likewise would be
problematic if the bill went forward as
is there are things that I think are val
valuable like some of the test strips
and other things so maybe it's worth
holding on and studying this I don't
know if that is an
option that would be an inm study
motion I would be willing to make that
motion second okay a motion made for
inim study on Senate Bill 239 with a
second by representative
kofalt any discussion now on the
motion representative tarki I don't
necessarily have a um discussion on the
motion I know that we had just pulled up
the doc it do we we know it passed the
house um the first committee when it
came through the house and to then bring
it to finance I'm just curious what the
vote was on that day I know it was close
but I'm
just I don't know if representative
kofalt has it that or I could look it up
too
sorry Whoever has it the quickest sure
so the first amendment was adoption of
the committee Amendment at 2491 1227
there was a subsequent floor Amendment
at
um but as representative Cal said some
others have since looked at this and
realized there's more work to be done
sorry can you just clarify what was the
ought to pass as amended vote on the
house floor uh that wasn't a roll call
that was a Voice vote I just oh it was
Voice vote thank you that answers my
question roll calls were only on the
adoption of I appreciate that thank
you okay representative Shapiro thank
you madam speaker
um as I said before or I was not someone
who was so particular about the
definition and the reason for that is
because I feel that there would be many
other guard rails along the way before
any other activities were actually
legitimized and implemented um so for
example safe injection sites which some
states use and um there seems to
be quite a bit of opposition to in New
Hampshire I think in order for something
like that to be imple mented there would
have to be funding there would have to
be um various kinds of permissions both
locally and and and by the state so I
think um with the definition of harm
reduction as is there are many guard
rails
for putting into effect or not putting
into effect um
various um harm reduction activities so
I would urge people to vote um ought to
pass thank you representative
H as I mentioned before having worked in
this field a little bit um I'm not sure
dealing with the mental health issues
that lead people to um start abusing
drugs and or alcohol and or other
substances um is going to be addressed
by safe injection
sites
representative
walner well I find myself in the same
place I am often on this committee is
that it feels
like these new concerns about this piece
of legislation all deal with policy and
the policy committee has done its work
and has sent it to us and we've really
we have not looked at the finances of it
I mean that's not the reason we are
going to continue studying it we're
studying it because of policy reasons
and um I feel like that the uh Health
and Human Services committee did its
work they passed us to us on the policy
they wanted us to look at the finances
which again we're digging into the
policy and not into the finances so for
that reason I'm going to vote against
the interim
study or the yeah whatever whatever it
is we do in the off
year study is the motion right uh which
it brings up a point it's my
understanding from the rules unlike a
retained motion the inim study motion
goes to the Full House the retained
Motion in year one does not year two uh
interim study does any further
discussion on an interim study motion
Senate Bill
239 all right I'd ask the clerk to call
the role when
ready the motion is interim study
representative Kofa yes representative F
yes representative hle
yes Representative
walner no represent nordgren no
represent tki
no representa grassy
no wer votes yes chairman Mooney
yes 5 to4 interim
study
okay 5 to four the motion carries so
Senate Bill 239 is an inm study
recommendation to the full finance
committee that's the next step here in
the process okay that concludes the
seven bills we have published publicly
for us to take up today any further
business from the members of the
committee thank you so much thank you to
our substitute Clerk and our two
substitute members appreciate all of the
time thank you representative for coming
and representative Horgan as well thank
you all we'll close this session on
division
three 39
done
that